d'après mon fils il était super sympa
super aimable super gentil la polémique
qui a eu comme quoi il aurait fait
sortir les enfants musulmans
mon fils m'a dit que ce n'était pas
juste pour les préserver c'était pure
cité par pure gentillesse quoi dans ce
qui devait montrer une caricature du
prophète de l'islam
il a tout simplement dit à vos enfants
ou d'enfants musulmans sortent et j'ai
pas envie que ça vous fait mal au coeur
c'est que mon fils ma tin
ils sont sortis voilà comment elle a
fait sentir dès les enfants n'étaient
pas pour ce n'est pas pour discriminer
quiquet qui que ce soit ou quoi que ce
soit comme ça c'était vraiment pour
laisser vraiment pour les préserver que
la sphère c'était réglé je crois deux ou
trois jours après il avait ramené
quelqu'un de l'éducation nationale
quelques parents étaient venus ils
étaient tous unanimes pour dire c'est un
homme qui a fait une erreur c'est
apparemment les réseaux sociaux avait
fait que ça envenimer les choses sans
parler